BRIAN EGAN: All right, thank you
so much for joining me today.
My name is Brian Egan.
And I'm going to be discussing
Flutter architecture, or what
I call Keep it simple, State.
Hopefully that'll
live up to its name.
So before I begin, I'll
just introduce myself.
I'm formerly a senior software
engineer at SoundCloud,
and before that at
Zappos, and so I
was working on large
scale consumer facing
like applications
for Android and web.
And so I kind of found Flutter
about a year and a half
ago and just started throwing
as much spaghetti at the wall
as I could, so I've kind
of developed the Redux
package with John.
I've also been helping to
contribute to the RxDart
package.
And then I started applying
all of these things
to flutter and to see what
really worked for Flutter.
And so I kind of wanted to talk
about my journey with that,
and introduce you to
a couple of concepts
that I found really helpful.
So I think two concepts
that are really fundamental
is that, number one,
your architecture
for your applications will
change over time, right?
Your requirements
are going to change.
You know, what you use
for an MVP or a prototype
won't quite be the same thing
that you use for, you know,
your app with like 400
to 600,000 lines of code
with a team of 20 people.
Those things are
just naturally going
to be different
from one another.
And so when you find yourself
sort of progressing, maybe
from a prototype
or an idea stage
into more of a team phase
or a maintenance phase,
I really recommend the technique
of layering your architectures.
I think this is a fundamental
concept we heard a bit about
yesterday, and I
kind of want to dive
a bit more into that as well.
So let's look at just
sort of some basics.
We've got a flutter
app, we want to start
updating the state
of the app, and then,
of course, when that happens
we want to rebuild our widget
tree, so you know we're
actually showing the changes.
Then, of course, as
we start to progress
we're going to need
to start to share
some data between
different widgets,
between different
screens in our app.
And then that's pretty
cool, but then we'll
actually need to start talking
to web services and databases,
of course, right?
You don't want this like
closed-off little app
that's just kind of
hanging out by itself.
And so how do we kind
of use some techniques
to make that work well?
Finally, as you're sort of
progressing past that ideation
and MVP stage, you're
going to want to make
your apps easy to maintain.
And of course, what comes
along with that is how do you
test these apps, right?
So if you're working for
a company like Zappos
and people are adding
items to the cart,
you want to make
sure that works,
right, you don't want them
to get to a checkout page
and all of a sudden
there's no products there.
No one's going to
be happy about that.
So yeah, let's kind of walk
through these challenges.
And I want to start first
with the building blocks
that Flutter provides.
So I think it's
important to sort of see
what the framework gives you and
think about when we can keep it
simple and when we can
use these building blocks,
and then when we might
need to naturally progress
past these building blocks
to more advanced solutions.
So the first thing, of
course, is the StatefulWidget.
This is sort of the bread and
butter of state management
for Flutter, right, and the
StatefulWidgets themselves
are pretty simple.
They just sort of take
in some properties,
and the constructor perams.
You know, in this case
it includes a title,
but it could include
some other information.
And then they sort of just
create this state class
that you write, and they
kind of get out of the way.
So let's look at
the state class,
because that's where actually
the interesting stuff starts
to happen.
So we've got MyHomePageState.
I literally stole this
just from the Flutter
create example, just to
keep it simple, you know.
And so now we've got, for
example, just our counter.
So this is the
first responsibility
of the state class,
is to define,
hey, what kind of
information does
my application need to render.
The second thing that the
state class will often contain
are methods to update the state.
And this is where it gets
a little interesting,
because we're not just
incrementing the counter,
but then you're also
using the set state method
from the state class.
And what that will do is
it'll run that function
that you give it.
And then after it
runs that function,
it'll actually tell
Flutter hey, go ahead
and rebuild this widget
tree, or mark this tree
for needing a rebuild.
Then finally, the third thing
that your state class often
does, or needs to
do, is actually
define the UI in
the build method.
So in this case, we'll
just pass the counter
that we've got to a text widget.
We'll pass that
increment counter
to a button of some sort so
that when you press on it,
it'll go ahead and
increment the counter,
tell Flutter to
rebuild that widget,
and then everything works.
So I think maybe some of you are
thinking like, OK, that's like,
a super simple example.
But I actually
think it has a lot
of really interesting
little concepts wrapped
up inside of it.
So you know our widget tree at
this point is really simple.
We've got a
StatefulWidget, and it's
sort of handing some information
off to a text widget,
and a count button.
It's handing off the increment
counter to a button widget.
But more often than
not, our widget trees
are going to be more
complex or interesting.
Your designers are going to
throw some cool stuff at you,
and they're going to ask you
to make some cool layouts.
And so you're going to start
nesting widgets a bit more,
and you might need to send
that data little bit further
down your widget tree.
And the most common way, and
the simplest way to do that,
is to simply pass the state
from your StatefulWidget
down the widget tree, right.
So say we need some
information, or we
want to pass our counter
and our increment
counter down to these
widgets that I'm
trying to highlight here.
So what we can do is, maybe
you've got a stateless widget,
you can create another
constructor parameter,
and it will take the counter.
It will pass that
counter further
down the tree to
another stateless widget
that takes in the counter,
and then finally that
will get rendered by a text
widget or something in the end.
On the other side
of our widget tree,
we want to pass down
increment counter,
and we can do this
infinitely deep.
We can actually continue to pass
values down the widget tree.
And this is a really
nice and kind of tidy
way to go ahead and
actually pass state around.
So then when you tap on
the increment counter,
or on the button that we've
passed increment counter to,
it will go ahead and call
that method, of course,
on the StatefulWidget.
The StatefulWidget
will say, hey,
I need a redraw at this point.
And then it'll once again
pass the counter back down
and display the new value.
Cool.
So this is actually a
really fundamental concept
of state management,
and it comes from React.
And it's a concept
called Lifting State Up.
And so the idea behind this is
that if you need to share data
amongst different
widgets, what you can do
is you can create a
StatefulWidget at the parent
or the root of those
different widgets
that need the
information, and then you
can pass the information
from the StatefulWidget
down to the different
parts that need it.
The interesting thing
is that this also
applies to sharing
data across screens,
because what you can
do is you can actually
pull the StatefulWidget all the
way up above your application.
So this is really cool.
We just heard Phil talk
about how everything
is a widget in Flutter,
and so what we can do
is we can just pull
that StatefulWidget
above your widgets app,
or your material app,
and that's the
actual widget that's
responsible for creating
different screens
in your application.
That's where you like
navigator.push some new route,
or navigator pop.
And so we can actually use this
technique to pass information
down to different screens.
So while it might seem simple
at first, you actually,
using this basic
technique, can start
to share data
amongst your screens
and have it re-render
every time data changes.
So let's keep going.
Let's progress.
We want to start calling web
APIs or maybe a database.
So now what we'll do
is we'll sort of start
to enhance our state class.
We'll throw a Boolean in there
of whether it's loading or not.
And that way our UI can show
a loading status or maybe,
or the actual counter,
if it's true or false.
And then what
we'll have is we'll
actually have a method within
our state class, that goes
ahead and talks to the API.
So we'll just call this
fetchIncrement for right now.
It'll return a future
with an integer involved.
And then we'll create
an HTTP client in there.
We'll actually go ahead
and wait for the client
to get the information
from our web server.
This is just some pseudo
code, but I'm just
trying to get the idea across.
Finally, we'll go ahead
decode that, that JSON,
and then we'll return the value
of the counter from the JSON.
Then actually, the method
we'll want to use in our UI
is called increment Async.
And so what this will
do is it'll immediately,
as soon as it gets
called, it'll go ahead
and say, hey, set state, I want
to show my loading spinners,
so show my state as loading.
Then we'll fetch the
increment from the API using
the method we just created.
And then after that
returns, we'll once again
set the state with the
counter set to the value
that we got back from the API,
and we'll set loading to false.
And so what this looks like,
again, with our widget tree
is that we'll pass
increment Async down.
When we tap on that,
then we'll go ahead
and re-render the widget tree.
The first render
will of course have
the loading state involved,
and we'll show the spinner.
And then when the data
comes back from the API
it'll go ahead and pass the
counter down, down, down,
and we'll see that the
new value is actually
rendered at this point.
Cool.
So you know,
looking good, right?
Some of you might be
breathing into a paper
bag with this architecture.
You might be like,
what is this guy doing?
Where's he going with this?
He's throwing everything
into one class.
Don't worry, friends.
We'll get there.
So we're actually updating
the state of our app,
we're talking to web APIs,
we're sharing information
across screens.
Not so bad, right?
If you're just
writing a prototype,
or you're just learning Flutter,
this is a totally great way
to get started.
You're going to start making
progress really quickly.
But you know, you're
going to start
running into these
issues, where if you
want to make your app
easier to maintain,
to bring team
members on, to share
code between different things.
Throwing everything in this
class might get a little hairy.
And we'll also look at how this
can be a challenge for testing.
So let's start to challenge
our UI a little bit.
Let's make a UI change.
So we want to move
the widget that
displays the counter from
this part of our tree
to this part of our tree.
Oh god.
What do we need to do?
We need to change this widget.
It no longer needs to accept a
counter, neither does this one.
The StatefulWidget
is actually lifted up
too high right now, so we can
make that a StatefulWidget.
Then we push the
StatefulWidget down one level.
Then we add a counter
parameter here,
and then we can pass it down.
So maybe not the best if
you want to start really
revving on UI changes.
You know, this can be a
good way to get started.
But if you want to start
making UI changes quickly
you're going to find hey,
this is actually maybe not
the cleanest or the
easiest way to do this,
because it requires a
lot of plumbing changes.
So let's take a look
at one solution, right,
and that's the inherited widget.
This is another
building block actually
that's provided by Flutter.
And so what it will do
is rather than having
the StatefulWidget pass state
directly down to its children,
the StatefulWidget
will actually pass data
to an inherited widget,
and then the responsibility
of that widget is to pass
that information down
to all of its ancestors
in the widget tree.
So we'll pass the private
counter and increment
counter down from
the StatefulWidget
to the inherited
widget, and then it
will expose those publicly.
So now, if we want that
data down our widget tree,
we can just say, My
Inherited Widget of context,
give me the counter.
On the other side we can say,
My Inherited Widget of context,
give me the increment
counter method.
And this makes it really easy.
So if we try that
challenge again,
let's say we want to
move the button this time
from this part of the tree
to this part of the tree.
OK, so we're just moving it.
Now this time it's really easy.
We don't have to do any of
that crazy plumbing or changes,
because we're still just
relying on the inherited widget
to pass that information
down the tree for us.
All right, it's not bad, right?
There's a lot less plumbing
now that we have to deal with.
It's easier to move widgets
around and change up
your UI quickly.
But you'll start to see
that there's actually
some interesting
duplication between what
lives in the state
class and then also
in the inherited widget.
And you'll also see that the
entire widget tree is actually
rebuilt when this happens.
You might have
seen that actually
with all of the
StatefulWidget examples.
And then, of course,
the big question
is, how do we test
all of this, right?
So let's look at another
challenge, which is testing.
So if we want to
test this thing,
like this was my
initial dream, is
I was just going to write
a plain old dart test.
I was going to instantiate a
new version of the state class.
I was going to run the
increment counter method
and then just be able to
expect that the counter has
gone from 0 to 1.
Now unfortunately, that's
not quite the way it works.
Because this is a
state class and it's
kind of tied to
Flutter, you actually
have to use the Flutter
testing utilities
to test this type of logic.
So what do we actually have to
do is we have to pump a widget.
In this case, I'll
pump the entire app.
I'm just doing that
for simplicity,
but you know sometimes
you might need
to add some extra
information in there,
like a directionality widget,
to get your stuff to render.
Then you have to find the
button on screen that actually
does the tapping and tap that.
You wait for Flutter to
re-draw the widget by saying,
OK, let's pump the tester,
and then finally you
would basically look
at the widget tree
that Flutter is rendering in the
test environment and say, hey,
is there a widget that's
displaying this text?
So if we kind of look
at that challenge,
we start to see that it's a
little bit harder to work with.
I don't want to judge the
widget inspector at all,
or the widget tester at
all, because it's amazing
that this actually exists.
If you come from Android,
it can be really a pain
to do this type of testing.
And it becomes clear
that this type of testing
is great for you
UIs and UI logic.
But you can start to see how
our architecture that we've
got right now, which might have
been great if you were starting
out, or great if
you've got an MVP,
is starting to break
down a little bit
because we're mixing so
many things into one class.
So hopefully for those of you
breathing into your paper bags
earlier, you're starting
to see that we will
overcome this challenge, right?
And so the other thing
is that if you're
testing complex scenarios, this
is almost impossible, right.
Say you're doing some
sort of interesting list
transformations,
or something like
that, to be able to test
it with the widget tester
would be really difficult.
And it becomes even messier
when Async code is
involved, and the reason
is that the test
widgets function does
some interesting
stuff to override
the way Async works in Dart,
which makes it a really--
makes it work really well for
widget tests, but not so--
it makes it a lot
more complex if you're
dealing with databases or APIs.
So what's the solution
to this problem?
And that is layering.
And so we heard a bit
about this yesterday,
and so let's dive into
this a bit more as well.
So you know, you might have
seen the layers in action.
This is a Flutter sort
of layered diagram.
But we can actually use layers
in our own apps as well.
And so if we look at the
responsibilities of our state
widget, it's got sort of three
responsibilities right now.
It's sort of defining
the state and learning
how to fetch data for that.
It's also got some logic
about how the counter should
get incremented.
You know, in a real
world application
you might have some
interesting rules around when
that counter can
actually get incremented,
or how it gets incremented.
And then finally, we
want to draw the UI.
And so all of that right now
is contained within one class.
So let's look at
how we can actually
start to break this out.
The first thing we'll
look at is the data layer.
So the data layer, the easiest
thing we can actually do
is just extract that function
out into its own file,
or something like that.
And then what we'll do is,
rather than creating the HTTP
client internally,
we'll actually
inject the HTTP client.
So you might have also seen this
exact technique used yesterday.
And the reason
it's so powerful is
because if you're in
a browser context,
you can provide
the browser client.
If you're in Flutter itself,
you can provide the I/O client.
And if you want to actually
test these functions,
you can provide a mock client.
And so this gives
you full control
over how and the
environment that you're
executing these
things in, and it's
really powerful for testing
and for sharing code.
Now, this function
could actually
be used cross-platform as well.
That's just a
natural sort of thing
that happens when
you extract it.
The rest of the function
is basically the same.
You know, we'll use
the client that we're
given instead of
creating it internally,
but the function remains
essentially unchanged.
So then we kind of come
to this domain layer.
And this is where you actually
have a ton of good options,
I actually think.
So I've been working
a lot with RxDart
and stream-based architectures.
There's also some other
interesting projects
called scoped model, which comes
from the Fuchsia code base.
I've just ripped
that out shamelessly
and published it
as a pub package
if you want to give it a shot.
And then the final thing is--
I mean, there's a
lot of options here.
But one of the popular ones
that I've seen coming up
is different types of
Redux architectures.
So I'll focus on that,
because that's a library I'm
helping to develop.
And so it's just the
Redux package on pub.
And so let's take a look
at how that would work.
So Redux itself is going
to be all pure Dart.
And so in this
case, what we'll do
is we'll define the
state of our application.
And so this is a little bit
different than the state class.
This just means what sort of
data does my application need.
And this might be
a list of to do's
or you know a list of
products, things like that.
But basically it's just
a plain old Dart object,
and it should be an
immutable Dart object.
And so you can use just
the immutable annotation,
or you can use built value, if
you like that kind of thing,
to create these sort of
immutable state objects.
In this case, we
only need to counter,
so we've got a super simple one.
The second thing
you'll need is, OK,
so you're like, OK,
your state's immutable.
How do you change it?
And so you change state in
Redux by dispatching actions.
And so for now we'll
keep it simple,
and we'll only have the
one action in our app.
Eventually you can define
many more of these.
And in Redux, these are
just simple either enums,
or maybe classes.
Classes are
necessary if you want
to deliver some payload
information, such as an ID,
along with the action.
So in our case,
we actually don't
need any payload
information, so we
can make it just a simple enum.
Then what we'll have is, in
order to update the state,
we'll have a function
that's called a reducer.
Now, this is kind
of a crazy name.
It's just a function that takes
in two parameters and returns
something.
So I don't know, reducer, don't
let that name is scare you.
I think it scares a
lot of people off.
It's like a monad or something.
Don't worry about it.
It's not a functor or
anything, or it probably is.
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
But yeah, so all
this function does
is take in the previous app
state and the current action
that's been dispatched, and it
will return a new app state.
And that's all there
is to it, really.
So in our case, once
again, because this is
a simple application,
we'll just say like, hey,
if the action that
was dispatched,
it was an increment
action, we'll
want to return a new
version of the app state
and increment the
counter while we do so.
If we don't know how to handle
the action like some jokers
just dispatching
some crazy actions,
we'll just return
the previous state,
you know, no harm, no foul.
And then we tie all this
together with the store.
So the store itself just takes
in one required parameter,
which is the reducer,
and you can optionally
provide an initial state.
And so what we can do
with this is then we
can immediately create the
store and start using it.
And so we can just
actually immediately
print out the store's state.
In this case, we just want
to print out the counter.
Since we're initializing
it with a counter of 0
it'll print that.
And then we want to
change the state,
so we'll start
dispatching actions.
So we can do a dispatch, we'll
dispatch our increment action,
and then at that point we can
print out the state again,
and it will be 1.
Notice that this
is all synchronous,
and that's sort of by
choice, because that
makes it a little bit easier
to work with and reason about.
So now let's take a look at
that testing challenge again.
Because we're just dealing
with a simple function,
we can actually write a really
easy test for this reducer.
So we'll actually
just test the reducer.
We'll just call that
function with a given app
state, the previous app state.
The action we give to it
will be an increment action.
And then we can expect that
the new state that's returned
from that is equal to 1.
And so you've actually
gained a lot of testability
here, because all of
this is just pure Dart.
It's all extracted out
of this state class.
You can actually really
easily test this,
and you can also share this
type of code cross-platform.
You know, that's not necessarily
the point of this talk,
but it's just a cool benefit
that you get for kind
of extracting this layer out.
So then let's talk
about the UI layer.
Because this is a Flutter talk,
I'm going to discuss Flutter.
But this stuff could also be
hooked up to Angular as well.
So in this case what we'll
do is we'll actually use
a library called
Flutter_Redux, which
sort of melds
Redux with Flutter,
and it provides something
called a store provider.
And that's a widget that
you put at the very top
of your hierarchy.
And guess what, it's
an inherited widget.
So that's really
cool, because that
means that the store
is being passed down
to all of the descendants.
So now if we need the data
at these points again,
we could just be
naive and actually use
the power of inherited widget.
So we could say,
hey, store provider,
give me the state of
the counter right now.
And on the other side,
we could have our button,
and when it's tapped
we'll say, OK, store,
I want you to
dispatch that action.
So this is going
to be interesting,
because then if we tap on this
thing, you might have noticed,
where's the StatefulWidget?
So how do we actually
tell Flutter to redraw?
So it will actually
dispatch this action.
The store will be updated.
But what about state
changes for Flutter, right?
So this is where we'll
introduce another concept
from Flutter_Redux, which is
called the store connector.
And this widget is actually
hopefully pretty simple.
But what it has is two
required parameters.
The first parameter is
what's called the converter.
So this will actually
be given the full store.
And you can convert that
into some type of view model.
So in this case, our widget
only cares about the counter.
So we'll just extract the
counter out of the state.
The next required parameter
is a builder method,
or builder function, and you
might have used these before.
There's like widget
builders, or if you've
worked with StreamBuilder,
it's got its own sort
of Async snapshot builder.
And so this will actually have
a builder method or function
that takes two parameters.
And the first is,
of course, the build
context which you always need.
And the second is
actually the view model
that you've gotten
from the converter.
So in this case we're just
extracting the counter,
so I'll just name the
view model counter.
It's the integer.
And then you can render whatever
widgets you want from this.
So if we try that tapping
action one more time,
we can go ahead and swap out
the store provider of context,
and grabbing the
counter directly
for our store connector widget.
Now when we tap on this,
it will update the store.
And the store will
actually emit changes,
and that's what the store
connector is listening to.
It's listening to
changes to the store.
And then it'll say, OK,
now that I'm connected,
I know that I need to redraw.
And so it will go ahead and
just redraw that one widget
that you provide.
All right, so if we try that
UI challenge we had earlier,
if we want to move the counter
that we're displaying from here
to here, we're all good.
We're using the store connector.
We're using our inherited
widgets that we used earlier,
and it's all good.
We can just do
that super easily.
All right, so we did it.
We can update the
state of our app.
We can rebuild when
the widget changes.
We're sharing data across
screens and across widgets.
We're hooking our widgets up
to databases or web services.
Now unfortunately, because this
is a bit of a shorter talk,
I couldn't describe the methods
that Redux has to do that.
But there's a good,
there's a good solution
for that with Redux.
And the other cool
thing is that we're
starting to gain some
really nice things, which
is that we're going to make
our app easier to maintain,
because we can test all
these things really easily.
They're all isolated,
so if you've
heard of the single
responsibility principle,
we don't have everything's sort
of stored in one class anymore.
We're sort of splitting
that logic out
into different logical units.
The other cool thing is
we get some bonuses here.
So the Redux code
itself can actually
be shared across the platforms.
And actually even,
in our data layer,
we can share that
across platforms,
which is really pretty cool.
We're getting some other
interesting benefits,
which is that you might have
seen we're only redrawing
part of the widget tree now.
Because the store connector
is the only thing that
cares about the state changes
and we haven't lifted our state
up to the very top, the only
widgets that will get rebuilt
are the store connector widgets.
Another really kind
of cool bonus of this
is that you can actually get
some really interesting crash
reporting.
So if you're working
with a big consumer app,
it's really natural
to have something
like Crashlytics or
Sentry so that when
users encounter errors.
It'll send a crash report
up, and you can actually
start to aggregate
those crash reports
and say like, oh
man, all of our users
are crashing on this screen
and this part of our app.
But a lot of times you're
like, how did that happen?
How do I reproduce it?
You know, you might be
getting some user reports,
or you might just have this
random line and a huge stack
trace in Crashlytics,
and you're like, oh god,
how do I deal with this?
And so this is really cool
because what you can do
is, if you use
something like Redux
or this type of
pattern, what you can do
is you could actually
say, OK, let's
send up the state
of the application,
and let's send up the last 10
actions that actually happened.
And now what you can do
is, you as a developer,
you can read that in
addition to the stack trace,
and you can actually
reproduce the actions
that the user took
really easily.
Another kind of interesting
benefit that I didn't quite
have time to talk about
is Redux was basically
built to work with hot
reload, and so you actually
have some Redux dev tools.
And so as you're
modifying your reducers,
if you have your Flutter
app running live next to it,
you can actually
change your reducers,
and it'll replay all of the
actions that have happened up
until that point.
And then it'll actually go
ahead and just redisplay that.
So it's really kind
of an interesting way
to work because maybe
you've added five
to do's to your to do
lists, and then you decide,
oh actually, I
want to add to do's
the top rather than the bottom.
It'll actually just go ahead,
recompute all of those things,
and show you the result of that.
The other, I think, thing that's
really kind of interesting
is that this is Redux is like--
I'm not, I'm not only trying
to sell Redux at love streams.
I actually think there's
some interesting stuff.
But I think it's
a proven concept.
You have a lot of big companies
like Airbnb and Netflix
and these types of companies
using this type of pattern
for a couple of years,
and they've sort of
done the hard work of
solving the challenges that
come with these types
of architectures.
And so there's a lot
of good resources
out there for how you can
structure your apps by feature,
how you can share code
across different apps,
things like that.
All right, so let's look
at a recap real quick.
So we started out with a really,
you know, it's not great code
but don't worry about it.
It's working for you,
if you have prototype
or if you're just
getting started,
feel free to throw everything
in your state class.
Like I said, don't worry if
that just like freaks you out.
It's not a big deal.
We want encourage newcomers
to learn these things
and to get better with them.
And if they can see
successes really quickly,
that's totally cool.
So the second thing
is that once you
start to run into some
maintenance issues,
consider layering as a
solution to that problem.
So yeah, this was a super simple
example with just a counter.
If you want to see a more
advanced version of this,
I've actually been
trying to publish
a few different examples of
how to build a to-do app using
lifting state up, using
inherited widgets,
using scoped model.
I've also got a couple of Redux
packages on there as well.
So yeah, please, please
check out fluttersamples.com.
I've got links to all these
different resources and all
these different
examples, in addition to
maybe just demonstrating how you
can write integration tests as
well, and how you can
share that data layer.
All right, thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]